you had a Widowmaker heart attack in the
middle of a half Ironman race
you know I hit the start line and I kind
of knew something was off um but I love
racing the best because I get the best
out of myself start to get this kind of
spreading pain through my chest and then
shooting pain down my left arm oh you
finished the race I finished the race
right yep after I finished I knew hey
this isn't this isn't right and that's
when the kind of the red flags really
started to go off they made the decision
to bring me to Jackson South hospital
and get me in with the Cardiology team
and all of a sudden there's a lot of
people around me you know I asked myself
am I gonna die is this it they have two
two children is Bill and Finn and Finn
was only eight weeks older that one so
definitely want to make sure I was
around for for both of them you aren't
Invincible no matter how fit you are and
I think that's a big thing for endurance
athletes of all levels we all think
we're Invincible when
fact is whereas you know can be as frail
as anybody else